[Music]
i am will kane and tonight
we examine the effort to re-segregate
america of course you've heard by now
the story of mayor
lori lightfoot in her attempt to bring
jim crow back to chicago city hall
lightfoot said she would only grant
interviews to black or brown journalists
in the windy city dropping a blackout on
white journalists
who visit the mayor's office life had
said she wanted to be quote
intentionable about prioritizing media
requests from reporters of color
over white journalists who according to
lightfoot overwhelmingly make up the
majority
of the city hall press corps she doubled
down on those comments yesterday
if i as the black woman mayor the first
ever
don't challenge us the collective us to
do better
to really make sure that in every
institution
it reflects the diversity and nuance and
texture
of our city than shame on me but as
controversy swirled around lightfoot's
racist impersonation of bull connor
d.c mayor muriel browser she wrote into
her defense
that we need to see more reporters that
look like the cities that they're
covering and that's been a discussion
i've had with editors around
this city and we want to continue
to urge them to hire people that
reflects the
cities well welcome to the decline of
america where in six
short decades we have gone from aspiring
to judge a man by the content of his
character
to aspiring that every reporter look
just like the politician they cover
where in 60 years we've gone from martin
luther king jr
to muriel bowser and lori lightfoot 2021
is starting to look a lot like 1961
a segregated america and look it's not
just in chicago
take a look at this story from just this
week from wellesley massachusetts where
parents filed a complaint with the
department of education
that the local school violated the 1964
civil rights act by inviting students to
a safe space
to grieve anti-asian hate crimes we
talked to you about that
last night well in wellesley
massachusetts all students grades 6
through 12 were invited to participate
well all students accept white students
the email invitation read as follows
note this is a safe space for our asian
asian american and students of color
emphasize
not for students who identify only as
white if you identify as white
and you need help to process recent
events please know i'm still here for
you
as well as your guidance counselor and
again
this kind of creep this kind of racial
segregation is infiltrating every aspect
of our culture
take a look at collegiate campuses at
universities across this great country
students at nyu recently pushed
for racially segregated dormitories and
at columbia college
here in university i'm sorry columbia
university here in new york city
they have put in place racially
segregated graduations
and now look this isn't on the same
level as those examples but look at lego
this is lego's newest line of diversity
toys
this separation to color coding living
up
to every stereotype from hairstyle to
skin color
looks like it could have been designed
by david duke
this is the opposite of martin luther
king's dream for america or
the american constitutional ideal that
every man was created equal
and thankfully these efforts to
re-segregate america like those from
lori lightfoot
well they are simply too much for some
like former presidential candidate
tulsi gabbard who tweeted mayor
lightfoot's blatant
anti-white racism is abhorrent i call
upon
president biden kamala harris and other
leaders of our country of all races
to join me in calling for mayor
lightfoot's resignation
our leaders must condemn all racism
including anti-white
now look there is a belief on the left
it's been popularized by books
like white fragility or how to be an
anti-racist and the foundation of it
was laid out in the now notorious
critical race theory
it's the idea that only white people can
be racist
the idea goes that racism is only
accompanied by
power and if a minority has no power
then they can't really
be racist that is really what they think
but you and i and every sane person know
that racism is an individual sin it's
declining to look at each other for who
we are
our character our soul our actions
and instead look at each other primarily
through our skin color
there can be white racists there can be
black racists
there can be racists of every color that
lego can possibly imagine
and tusty gabbard is right lori
lightfoot's order is not
let's be clear race based it's not
reverse racism
let's call it what it is it is racist
and if joe biden is as opposed to
discrimination and racism as he
acted last night he should do as
tulsi gabbard has asked him to do and
call
for racist lori lightfoot's resignation
hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else